WELL THAT'S THE QUIETEST I'VE
HEARD THIS A FLOOR IN QUITE
SOME TIME.
WOULD EVERYBODY
PLEASE TAKE THEIR SEATS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. BUT EVERYONE PLEASE
TAKE THEIR SEATS. AS CHAIR OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY I HAVE THE HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE OF WELCOMING TO THE
ST CHAMBERS HERE ABOUT THE
STATE OF OUR JUDICIARY HELLO
CHIEF JOB POST A CUT. SORRY IT
IT HAS BEEN MY PARTICULAR TO
WHAT PART THIS WILL CHIEF
JUSTICE STATED THE JUDICIARY AS
ONE B. GETS THE BEST OUR TASTE
SENATE. I JUST ARE PART OF THE
JOY SCORED COMMIT THEY WOULD GO
TO THE BACK OF THE WHOLE HE'S
SENT. BRADFORD MALL THING AN
ARM BURKE. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CHARCOAL JOKE STORY- AND STONE.
YOU WILL BE ESCORTING THE CHIEF
TO THE ROSTRUM. I NOW HAVE THE
HONOR AND THE DEEPEST PRIVILEGE
OF INTRODUCING AT THIS MOMENT
THE SPEAKER OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON OWN. MAKE SOME OPENING
REMARKS SPEAKER INTO THE DICE
IS YOURS. AND HAVING MISSED MY
CUE R. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU
TO PLEASE BRING THE CHIEF JOB
TO THE- TO AT THIS. TIME LADIES
IN CHEAP CHEAP CHEAP.
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
GOOD
AFTERNOON AT FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU SENATOR JACKSON IT'S A
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS AGAIN FOR THE
JUSTICE ANNUAL ADDRESSED ON THE
STATE OF CALIBRATION SHARE.
ALMOST A THE GOOD DRAMATIC
ANNOUNCEMENT HE WAS SUSPENDING
THE DEATH PENALTY SHORTLY AFTER
THAT OUR CALIFORNIA CHIEF
JUSTICE GAVE A STATED THE
ADDRESS IN WHICH HE WORE WE
MUST. HOW MANY MONEY DOES NOT
TRANSLATE INTO A TWO TIERED
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE. THE WORDS OF
THESE TWO LEADERS SHOULD GIVE
CALIFORNIANS PRIDE. I AM PROUD
TO SEE THAT THEY ARE SPEAKING
UP JUSTICE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. IN THE END IN
THE JUDICIARY. ASSEMBLY HAS
ALSO STOOD FOR JUSTICE WE STAND
FOR JUSTICE WHEN WE PASS
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT CRITICAL
RIGHTS FOR WORKING PEOPLE ORDER
CHECK THE VERY FIVE YOUNGER MEN
AGAINST REASONABLE WORSE. RIGHT
NOW OKAY DURING HIS THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
REPRESENT A TRIPLE DOUBLE WORK
INSTANT JUSTICE AT THIS MOMENT
IT'S MY HONOR TO INTRODUCE MY
PARTNER IN THAT PLEDGE JUST.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU
IT IS REALLY A JOY TO HAVE YOU
AS MY LEGISLATIVE PART MY
COLLEAGUE AND MY- AND- GOOD.
NEWTON AND WELL TO THE TWENTY
TWENTIES OF THE JUDICIARY
ADDRESS. TO THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS THE REPRESENTATIVES
THE LEGAL COMMUNITY IN THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HERE TODAY AND
ALL OF OUR OTHER DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS MORNING THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME. TODAY I ALSO WANT
TO. A FEW OF OUR OTHER PARTNERS
IN STATE GOVERNANCE STARTING
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE AND OUR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AT LANEY COULD LOCK US.
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVEA
SERRA. OUR STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY YEE HAW. OUR STATE
TREASURER FIONA MA. SO LET ME
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
OUR SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT IS
PRECIOUS. THE LEGISLATIVE
JUDICIAL AND EXECUTIVE BRANCHES
SAFEGUARD OUR DEMOCRACY WITH
EVERY SINGLE STEP THAT WE TAKE.
AND AS A CO EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT THE JUDY BRANCH WORK
DAILY TO INTERPRET LAWS THAT WE
ENACT TO PROTECT AND FURTHER
OUR DEMOCRACY. ONE THE NEARLY
NINE BEING. AND IN CAL. THE
SUPREME COURT ISSUES AS MANY AS
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DECISIONS
EACH YEAR. THE OPINIONS
ULTIMATELY AFFECT THE LIVES OF
OUR STATE'S FORTY MILLION
RESIDENTS AND MAKE RIPPLE
ANNOUNCEMENT APPEARS PRUDENT
NATIONALLY AND IN FACT WE BY.
HELLO THE GROANING. DIVERSE SO
HAS OUR SUPREME COURT GROWN
REFLECTIVE OF OUR GREAT STATE.
IT'S BOTH OF AND PLEASURE ENTER
CAL. THE COURT JUST. ING WITH
JUST A CHAN JUSTICE TEN LET ME
MY CAN. ON YOUR IMPENDING
RETIREMENT MAY YOU ENJOY IT
IMMENSELY YOU HAVE EARNED THIS
LET ME THANK YOU PUBLICLY FOR
YOUR SERVICE. WE THAT. OUR
ASSOCIATE JUSTICES ARE WITH US
ALSO TODAY CAROL CORRIGAN IS
HERE. GOODWIN LIU IS HERE WITH
US. MARIANO FLORENTINO QUAY ARE.
AND JOSHUA GROSSMAN. AND NOW
FRIENDS COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING TO THE SENATE
CHAMBER CALIFORNIA'S CHIEF
JUSTICE TANI CANTIL SECOND AWAY.
THANK YOU IT IS A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE THANK YOU SENATE
PRESIDENT ATKINS THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON THANK YOU
SPEAKER RENDON. YOU TOO ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS HERE ON
THE PODIUM AND OF COURSE IN ALL
WAYS THANK YOU LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR COLONEL AKIS IT'S A
PLEASURE AGAIN TO BE HERE WITH
ALL OF YOU. DURING THAT
CELEBRATE. ONE HUNDRED
ANNIVERSARY OF THE NINE THE
GIVING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE
I'M CERTAIN. THAT OUR
SUFFRAGETTE ANCESTORS WOULD BE
PROUD TO SEE SO MANY CALIFORNIA
WOMEN LEADERS IN THE WORLD. I'M
ALSO PROUD TO BE HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SUPREME
COURT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE BENCHMARK
COALITION CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND THE STATE R.
I'M ALSO THANKFUL THAT SOME
FRIENDS AND- WE ARE HEARING. MY
HUSBAND MARK. AND OUR DOG ANNA
AND. I'D LIKE TO TAKE A TO OF
AN NEWSOM HIS PROCLAMATION.
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH HAS THREE.
TO HONOR THE SACK AND DEALING
HAVE JAPANESE AND WHO IT AND
DUE PROCESS WERE FORCED FROM
THEIR HOME TO LIVE IN A MIN FOR
YEARS AND TO THOSE PEOPLE.
DOROTHY SOCCER.
ZERO WAS
INTERNED AT TULE LAKE
CALIFORNIA AND DOROTHY WAS INTO
BURNED AT A MARQUEE COLORADO IT
IS PROBLEM MATE THE GOVERNOR
WENT ON IGNITE MEN LIKE MY
NINETY ONE YEAR OLD FATHER IN
LAW JUROR WHO IS FROM THE CAMP.
EVADE VOLUNTEERED FOR THE
UNITED MAY AND- IN WHAT. I ALSO
WANT MAKE THE S. PRETTY SO RENT
AND AT SOME MEMBER MERA CHI FOR
THEIR RESOLUTION A POLY APOLOGY
FOR THE THEN CALIFORNIA ALLEGES
CO IN IN THE IN TURN. AS
AMERICANS DURING WORLD. I ENDED
IN THE SENATE WILL BE C. A
SIMILAR. INTRODUCED BY SENATORS
PAN AND ACCIDENTS. I WANT TO
SAY THAT THESE ACTIONS OF
REMEMBRANCE AN APOLOGY IN A
TIME OF NATIONAL BANS
XENOPHOBIA THE HOSPITAL.
BEACONS OF HOPE WHEN OUR
CALIFORNIA LEADERS TAKE THIS
KIND OF ACTION. I ALSO WANT TO
SAY THAT I KNOW AND THAT WE CAN
REPLY THAT THE THREE BRANCHES
OF GOT AN OUR CALIFORNIA
LEADERS WILL KEEP THEIR HEADS
THERE CORRECT CHRIS EVANS. AT
KEEP US SAFE. TEXTED IN THE
COVER STATE OF THE STATE HE
TALKED ABOUT THE COW GAME HE
DIDN'T DIFFER IT HE DIDN'T HAVE
TO ALL OF US KNOW WHAT THAT IS
AND THAT'S WHY WE TO TAKE
MOMENT TO IT NOW. JUSTICE MING
WHO PERSONIFY THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM HE IS A PERSON OF
EXTRAORDINARY INTELLECT GAIN
BUT ONLY INDUSTRIES BUT FROM
HANDS ON HARDWARE AND X. I JUST
POSSESSES ARRAY WAS AND IN YOUR
REFERENCE WIT HIS STORY BEGAN
WHEN HIS. GREAT AUNT'S AGAIN
POTATO FARMERS ONE OF. GREAT I
HATE AND A COMBINE BEFORE HE
COULD. HIS PARENTS NEVER
FINISHED ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BUT
THEY KNEW THE VALUE OF AN
EDUCATION AND SO THEY SENT ME A
THING BORED WITH THE LOCAL. H.
TRUE JUDGE. THIS JUDGE HAD
MEANING THE MIDDLE SCHOOLER
READ BLACKSTONE'S COMMENTARIES
ON THE LAWS OF ENGLAND.
SURPRISINGLY DID NOT
DETERMINING FROM THE PRACTICE
OF LAW. HE. WENT ON TO SERVE IN
THE MILITARY AS A U. S. CAPTAIN
IN VIETNAM. DECORATED VETERAN
HE THEN CAME BACK IN TURN
TENSION TO THE LAW AND AGAIN HE
EXCELLED. GIVEN HIS MANY
DECADES OF PUBLIC SERVICE AS A
LAWYER JUDGE AND JUSTICE. HE-HAS BECOME AN EXPERT IN
TECHNOLOGY AND IN THE SCIENCE
IN A HE CO CHAIR OUR JUDICIAL
SOUL LET'S SEE RULE MAKE BOUGHT.
ANY TEN YEARS. THIS IS TO DAY.
WELL ON HIS B. AS HE EXITS.
INTELLECT THAT INTEGRITY OF OUR
OVER THOUSAND CORE OFFICER ON
OUR- TWENTY THOUSAND COURT
EMPLOYEES. JUSTICE MING CHIN IS
A JUROR WITHOUT PARALLEL HIT
TWENTY FIVE YOU WISE AND
PRACTICAL JURISPRUDENCE ON THE
CALIFORNIA COURT WILL. EIGHT TO
COME. ONE IS LIKE AS YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF WHO WE- DONE BUT I
ACTUALLY KNEW BEFORE I MET HIM
AND I'LL TELL ABOUT THAT IN A
FEW MOMENTS. HERE IN NOW. THIS
LEGISLATURE YOU GRAPPLE WITH
THE STATE'S MOST VITAL ISSUES
FROM HOMELESSNESS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. TO HEALTHCARE TO
EDUCATION TO OUR AGING
POPULATION AS WELL AS FUNDING
OF LITIGATION THREATS FROM OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
UNDERMINE BILITY TO DRESS THESE
USE. ALSO WE MET LAST YEAR
ALONE OVER EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S BILLS RESPOND AT
ALL. THESE LOGS WERE THE
PRODUCT OF DELIBERATION
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE RIGHTLY
IMPROPERLY YOU HELP YOURSELVES
THE BALL. HELD OTHERS
ACCOUNTABLE. NOW IT STATES THAT
DOES NOT SOONER OR LATER BECOME
A JUDICIAL ONE. SO YOUR ISSUE
GIVE IT TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
AND WE BECOME ACCOUNTABLE.
ACCOUNTABLE OF COURSE WITH OUR
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL PUBLIC
HEARINGS WE RELY ON THE FACTS
TO MAKE FINDINGS OF FACT AND OF
COURSE THE RULE OF LAW. BUT
ALSO WHAT WILL AN A.'S BECAUSE-
THIS IN THE NAME OF AND WE DO
IT UNDER THE BANNER OF THREE
DIMENSIONAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THAT IS THAT IT IS B. E. ALL
THAT IT PHYS AND IT BE. TAKE
FOR A COUPLE TIME IN IT GRANT
FUNDING TO THE JUDICIAL QUE. WE
DO. THAT TRIAL COURTS BASED ON
OUR ABILITY TO INCREASE EQUAL
AT. IN THE RESTRICTIONS. SOME
OF THE PROGRAM INCLUDE A HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PREVENTION COURT IN
FRESNO THAT PROVIDES A PLACE
FOR VICTIMS TO COME FOR SUPPORT
SAFETY AND SOCIAL SERVICES. IN
SAN FRANCISCO THEY DEVELOP A
VETERANS COURT THAT SEEKS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND AND ENTREAT
AND IN WOMEN WHO SERVE THIS
COUNTRY BUT HELP LOST WAY WHEN
THEY CAME HOME. UNDER THE
BANNER. FULL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
WITH THE HEALTH. TO REPAIR
MAINTAIN OUR OVER FIVE HUNDRED
COURT FACILITIES AS WELL AS
BUILD NEW BUILDINGS IN CRITICAL
AREAS AS YOU KNOW. UNDER THE
BANNER OF ONLINE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE WE'VE HELPED BUTTE
COUNTY AND RURAL COURT USERS
WHO COME TO COURT OR WHO NEED
SELF HELP. AND SO THIS GUY
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO EXPAND RURAL
HELP THE TWENTIETH OTHER JURORS.
AND IT HEY WE LEAD TO A MOBILE
APP THAT PERMITS TO THOSE YOU
TO ACT COURT CASES IN CALENDAR.
AND PAID. ASSESSED AND WITH A
FAST AND ALSO THE CONSEQUENCES
OF GOVERNMENT ACTION NEGLECT
AND MISSTEPS THAT HAPPENED
BEFORE ANY OF US WERE HERE. BUT
IN RECENT TIMES ALL OF US HAVE
COME TO UNDERSTAND THAT RACIAL
AND INCOME INEQUALITY CAN OFTEN
CREATE BARRIERS TO ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND AFFECTS THE
DEMOCRACY. OF ASK EXPERIENCES
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HI IS RATE IN THE NATION. IN
CAPS YEAH WE HAVE OVER FIFTY
CENT OF THE NAME. ASIAN STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE WORK TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES TO
IDENTIFY AND REFORM SYSTEMS OF
INEQUITY. DURING MY
ADMINISTRATION HE HAD CHAMP THE
NEED OF IMPOVERISHED AND THE
OVERLOOKED WE HAVE DEVELOPED
AND WORKED ON MANY PROGRAMS
INCLUDING WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
LEGAL. ON THE TRACK. IT PLAYED
YOUR BROTHER. IS WITH THE P.
WAS TO RESTORE. WE HAVE IN FACT
DEVELOP PRE TRIAL SERVICES AS
AN ALTERNATIVE TO MONEY BAIL
THAT PREYS UPON MINORITY
COMMUNITIES AND THE POOREST OF
THE POOR. WE HAVE PILOTED FINE
AND FEE REFORMS IN ORDER TO
RESTORE FAIRNESS AND BALANCE
AND PUT ANALOGY TELL WHEN COME
CALIFORNIA. WE CONTINUE TO SEEK
ASSISTANCE FOR OUR DEPENDENT
CHILDREN AND ARE WORKING TO
REPRESENT THEM. IN DELIVER NEWS
TO PEOPLE WHO NEED SELF HELP
AND FOR PEOPLE THANK YOU JUST
AS QUICKLY ARE WHO ARE UNABLE
TO STAND ENGLISH AS WELL AS
THEY NEED TO BE FOR COURT
SERVICES. WE DO ALL THIS AND WE
ASK THEN FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT IN OUR BUDGET SO WE CAN
CONTINUE THESE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS A NEW ONE.
THE COURT NAVIGATOR PROGRAM THE
COURT NAVIGATOR PROGRAM IS A
HUMAN TOUCH FOR PEOPLE WHO COME
TO COURT WITHOUT AN ATTORNEY
AND ARE IN CRISIS. IF YOU LOOK
AT THE BRANCH OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS YOU WILL COME TO
READ IT AS AS I HAVE. THAT
WOULD COME ON BOARD A THAT
RESOLVES. WE TIMES FIRST JUST
AS- AN AS CHIEF JUDGE. I HAVE
GONE OUT OF MY CONSCIENCE
DEMANDED IT. ON MATTERS
CONCERNING FINES AND FEES.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
MISCONDUCT AND UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
IN THE JUDICIARY. AND FIT ALL
IMMIGRATION INTERFERENCE AND
UPSTAGED THE SYSTEM. THIS IS
WHY IN PART I BELIEVE THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE BECOME SOCIAL
JUSTICE CENTERS. I OFTEN SEE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN A CRISIS THAT
COULD LEAD TO HOMELESSNESS I
WILL BE APPOINTING A WORKGROUP
THE HOW WE CAN BECOME PARTNERS
IN THE CRISIS OF HOMELESS. AND
THIS WORK. THIS WORK GROUP WILL
REPORT BACK TO ME AT THE END OF
THE YEAR AND WILL CONSIDER
QUESTIONS LIGHT. HOW COURTS
BECOME MORE PROACTIVE IN
ADDRESSING HOME POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE THERE TOOLS AND
FEATURES IN LAWS THAT NEED TO
BE A MAN OR MY- WE BET FIRST.
THE POP. THAT COME TO OUR
THAT'S- WE FOR ARE STILL
PROPERTY. AND IT REPURPOSED FOR.
IS THERE A WAY FOR EXAMPLE CAN
USE OUR ASSIGNED TO PRO FOR
TARGET SERVICE SO THAT COURTS
CAN USE THEM FOR IT IS FOR
PEOPLE ARE IN CRISIS. WANT TO
TELL YOU THAT I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT THE JUSTICE WE DO TODAY
WILL AFFECT OUR COMMUNITIES OF
TOMORROW. AND THAT IS WHY I
WANT TO TELL YOU WHAT IT IS I
KNEW OF CHESTER'S CHICKEN IN
OUR HIS NAME AT THE SUPREME
COURT. THAT'S WHAT I'M I KNEW
HIM BEFORE. MET HIM. RECENTLY
ASKED ABOUT WHICH OPINIONS OR
DECISIONS HE WAS MOST PROUD AND
HE CITED A DESCENT FROM WHEN HE
WAS A COURT OF JUSTICE AND IN
THE DISSENT ARGUED THAT WOMEN'S
IN ROME BE A LITTLE DEFENSE IN
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROP YOU
SHOULD. BUT OF COURSE HE WITH
THE DISSENT ON THE COURT OF
APPEAL. SO BUT WHEN HE BEAT HIM
AS A CREAM COURT JUSTICE
AUTHORED AN OPINION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
RECOGNIZING BATTERED WOMEN'S
SYNDROME AS A DEFENSE IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES. THAT
WAS THE NINETY. IN NINETEEN
SEVEN I'M CREATING THE FIRST
EVER DEMAIS VIA. IN WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE A MY COLLAB COURT
ORDER OF JUSTICE BECAUSE- AN-
JUST DECISION RECOGNIZING WOMEN
SYNDROME IS GROUNDBREAKING.
BECAUSE IT FINALLY ALLOWS US TO
UNDERSTAND THE PATH OLOGY OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND ALSO
EFFECT NOT ONLY ON THE VICTIM
AND NOT ONLY ON CHILDREN OR THE
FAMILY. BUT ON FUTURE
GENERATIONS IT CHANGED THE
LEGAL LANDSCAPE FOREVER.
LOUDEST A WINDOW OF TERRIFYING
WINDOW INTO THE T. R. THE LIFE
OF THE VICTIM. SO I SAY THANK
YOU JUST CHIN FOR YOUR PUBLIC
SERVICE YOUR VISIONARY
LEADERSHIP BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT YOU DEMONSTRATE THAT WHEN
WE ARE OPEN MINDED WHEN WE DO
OPERATE FAIRLY AND WHEN WE COME
TOGETHER FOR AN ASSIST. ENGINE
THAT CAN PRESERVE AND CREATE
EXPAND ACCESS TO JUSTICE ALL
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
HE DOES THIS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HONORING US WITH YOUR
PRESENCE TODAY AND SHARING THE
STATED THE JUDICIARY-
COLLEAGUES- THE COUNCIL'S.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S RECEPTION
WILL BE FOLLOWING AT THE
STANLEY MOSK BUILDING AND SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY WE ARE SO
FORTUNATE TO HAVE SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE SUPREME COURT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LEAD
BY AN INCREDIBLE
LEADER AND A WONDERFUL WOMAN
THANK YOU CHIEF JUSTICE. THANK
YOU.